ladies and gentlemen welcome to screen
junkies movie fights powered by the
popcorn Talk network now your host Andy
signor hey screen junkies welcome it's
Super Bowl Sunday and you're here
watching movie fights how exciting
you're either getting ready for the big
game or you don't give a crap about the
big game and hopefully you're watching
us instead Sports either way welcome um
I'm so excited this is such a fun week
we there was a lot of big news this week
so I'm glad we have some stuff to to
talk about um obviously at the end
actually we have a couple I'm going to
tease a couple things at the very end so
stay tuned next week's movie fights is
going to be a big one I'm going to tease
this week's honest trailer so stick
around to the end you'll get some teases
um also big news A Fantastic Four
trailer dropped uh Ghostbusters cast the
Indiana Jones reboot with Chris Pratt
we're going to go through all of that uh
as always if you don't like a fight
we're talking about bottom right corner
on YouTube you can skip ahead to the
next battle so please just fast forward
don't leave uh also I have to thank our
friends here popcorn Talk network schmoo
podcast Network all those guys I love
all the shows the channels that they're
bringing us we're so happy to be here
we're so happy to be part of the family
please check them out links in the
description below and obviously also
we're also on YouTube I'm sorry on
iTunes um so be sure to subscribe to us
there comment rate all the things that
you do on iTunes now that that's all out
of the way let's meet our Challengers
for today uh you known from Hest
trailers he writes the game trailers the
regular trailers he writes a lot of
stuff for us over here it's Spencer
Gilbert yeah thank you for having me
back Andy I don't care what these two
were saying earlier you're a great judge
and a handsome man thank you very much I
appreciate that someone's calling me so
I'm turning off my phone uh next to him
we're so happy to have her here it's
Alicia Malone from scho no I'm really
nervous oh don't be nervous terrible to
bite us don't guys are only like the
most aggressive meanest Fighters we
have she was great on screen junkies
already you're going to kill it I'm so
happy you're here we're Ro I'm rooting
for you I'm not allowed to but I am
movie fights not movie friends that's
right next to her you know him you love
him he's uh Nick Mundy's mortal enemy
and he's from imockery
is itom yeah and youtube/ Roger barar it
is an education actually yeah uh thanks
for having me back man and uh you know
uh welcome to the show and uh just
because you're not Nick mondy doesn't
mean I'm against punching you so just
letting you know I will punch a girl in
fact I'm sitting in Mundy's seat right
now which is weird there's like this
weird like stench of failure in in this
seat so I don't know I I TW com feels
wrong it just feels can't wait for the
barrage of tweets Sunday responding to
that and next and on the couch it's the
Dan Cam he's been out for a while he's
back in it's our Undisputed champion of
movie fights oh I dispute it now Dan
welcome now to be clear to the fans and
to you I want to make sure you're up on
this as well we've now uh you won a
battle last week uh 19 comic book 19 won
a battle winner of this battle and comic
book 19 are going to take you on not
next week we have a different special
fight next week which we'll we will hype
at the end but the week after he's going
to put the belt on the line so one of
you could be wearing that belt is what
the moral is here I want that belt uh
even though I I suspect that he showers
with
it um to be fair he had it in the car
guys we made him bring it out he's not
that we're moving oh did you saw him
last episode look the smug look on his
face I had to intimidate Mundy I was
trying to throw Mundy off his game and
it worked I don't know I think you're
pretty proud of that man he is very
proud and you guys will be two if you
win it so let's get to the battles and
see if you got a shot uh I'm excited
let's start it in the great words of
William
Wallace will you
[Applause]
[Music]
fight for the
intro
start all right the first trailer for uh
the first trailer for Fantastic 4 Dro
finally there was been so much like
drama and things surrounding this movie
we finally got to see what oh they're
actually making a movie it's not a train
wreck they shot a movie um I think some
of the news made it feel like they
weren't even really able to make a cohes
cohesive movie so it's finally there we
got our first taste of it question
number one round
one John uh oh I can't say that right
kianis kis kianis John K I apologize Kon
konas
just he asks on Twitter uh did the
Fantastic Four trailer get us excited
about the new movie did it do its job
Spencer starting with you yes it did get
me personally excited I think you
mentioned that before how everyone's
expectations could not have been lower I
was not excited for this movie until I
saw the trailer I don't think Josh
Tran's mother was excited for this movie
until the trailer came out and it showed
us a couple things that are pretty
interesting number one it's not a found
footage movie which people were worried
about you know everyone thought it was
going to be Chronicle 2.0 and it looks
cinematic that's something to say
it looks like a movie really making it
something to say like a professional
okay moving on the cast is sneakily
amazing seeing them all together you've
got like Michael Jordan coming off of uh
fruit fail station um Kate Mar from
House of Cards uh Miles Teller from
Whiplash like these are the best four
young actors in Hollywood you could say
right now you can make that argument and
seeing them all together one could say
seeing them all together is pretty
exciting um you know this bleeds into
the next question but I like that
they're doing a serious take on the
Fantastic 4 we've already seen what the
silly ridiculous Fantastic 4 movie looks
like it came out in 2005 it was called
Fantastic 4 and it was terrible so I'm
excited that they're taking this in a
New Direction and Dan can you fact check
is J trunks's mom actually excited see
if you can find I spoke with Mrs TR last
night she is and she's on make sure
she's alive she's on the fence oh she's
on the fence positive okay in conclusion
that this is benefiting from everyone's
low expectations but it exceeded my low
expectations where do you stand are you
excited I'm not excited by the trailer I
I do agree that the movie looks looks
great in terms of the cast the cast is
great I like the director but as for the
trailer itself it is such a paint by
numbers trailer I feel like I've seen
that trailer so many times with the Grim
looks and then the narration I feel like
I could edit that trailer and something
that I'm really looking forward to
seeing in Fantastic 4 is the four of
them together we don't get to see that
in the trailer and I'd love to see them
speak as well I know it's a teaser
trailer and there'll be more in the
future cuz it's coming out in August but
as for this trailer it doesn't get me
excited because I just want to see more
right now I'm just me I'm on the fence
Miles Teller mumbles something at the
end Roger where do you stand worried
about I I'm not excited about it uh the
Fantastic 4 have always been kind of a
kind of a group to me in general uh I
I've always felt like there's better
versions of each of their characters
like Mr Fantastic I'd rather see Plastic
Man uh you know Wonder Woman is cooler
than the invisible woman and her
invisible jet I like that more uh the
Hulk uh is better than the thing uh I'm
just not that but none of those two
people are in the same group right I I
know but they're they're not that
interesting even when they're together
they're just not that interesting
characters um and on on top of it the
trailer I mean it's basically
Interstellar is the trailer and I loved
Interstellar but that I know I know I
know but uh the the trailer there it's
like a carbon copy they yeah they they
even have like a a truck or or just some
like beat up car driving through
Farmland with dust scattering up behind
it that is Interstellar that is
absolutely Interstellar so I don't know
I'm just there's just nothing in it
that's making me go oh man I got to see
it plus we have visual confirmation that
the thing is CGI I mean he is CGI there
and the one good thing I can say about
the other Fantastic Four movies is that
they actually did a pretty good job on
the things costume and I I really do so
do you like that the Hulk is you don't
like that the Hulk is CGI in event you
want the plastic uh costum you want
Michael chicklas I I just want to see a
real person interacting with these guys
and stuff they said that they kept his
eyes that was their big thing they kept
the character eyes he's soive see I got
to see his face but uh nevertheless it's
just one of those movies that I'm just
not that interested in seeing we do know
he wasn't wearing pants we do know that
that was the most exciting part of the
trail Rocky dong and probably the the
only time we saw them together um all
right so thought here's what's exciting
though is that we didn't even know that
this was going to be a movie forget
visual confirmation that the thing was
showing up we were like what is this all
we know is that uh it started late and
there were problems and he may have like
trashed his hotel room the fact that
this looks like a by the Numbers boring
kind of interstellar thing is a huge win
for me and I'm excited like oh he maybe
might have pulled something off here and
that's exciting but I don't think
production uh problems lead to it not
becoming a movie they put so much money
into it it has to be a movie it's going
to be a movie they're going to make
something of it Titanic had massive
problems and went on to be a huge hit
and they're releasing this trailer
pretty late you know know for a movie
that's coming out the summer I mean that
does not show a lot of confidence on
their part in What has been filmed and
stuff so how many people do we think in
the studio were sitting around watching
that trailer take giving notes to ensure
that that trailer I think a
lot it's not just me thinks that there
was clearly a te they went the CER the
tra and just kept it very standed
they're like yeah Interstellar got
people excited let's uh let let's just
do the same thing we got astronauts in
this movie perfect and I'm totally fine
with that this is an Interstellar this
is a movie that No One Believes In and
now this has somewhat maybe of a chance
of being good being it's about being
exciting about it yeah and that's it's
just not I'm excited for The Underdogs
I'm pulling for it I believe in this
movie I'm just curious do any of you
read the comics like who I know you said
you're not a fan like so none of you are
actually even hardore no one's a fan of
the Fantastic that's why that's why the
trailer has to make you excited it has
to make people like me who know nothing
about the comics excited and so far it
hasn't Spencer any other L points you
know I think that you guys are all being
too hard on it um that this we really
don't know enough yet and this gave us
enough to give hope that this might be a
good movie and that's something it the
only it gives hope that you know it's a
movie that you could watch yeah which is
exciting from the movie
you on not something you'd want to go
see in the theater it's just it's just
not that interesting it really isn't uh
you know it went from zero interest to
0.1 interest and to me that's exciting
that's not exciting yeah I don't know I
don't think that's
exciting doesn't sound like even you're
excited I'm sure arguing Devil's ADV
should have stated at the beginning at
least I got to go I got I don't think we
sort of on an impa cuz there's not much
more to argue about it I don't want to
keep it going but I think what you said
uh uh Alicia was give me the book it was
so paint by numbers was a very good
argument you were close but then you
lost me and what the hell's the thing
supposed to be if he's not CGI I don't
understand what you're talking about
have have you not seen the other fantas
fantastic form silly Batman and Robin
plastic suit no they actually made him
look good in those that's the one part
of those movies everyone has said it Dan
fact check that all right I think Mark
Ruffo as Hulk looks even cooler no he
looked so does Cesar the AP I we've
gotten a point where we can make the CI
work what what the Hulk does like
physically and you know just
acrobatically jumping over buildings and
stuff is way more than what the thing
ever really does this is going to break
into our our next our next fight well
let's save that so but anyway point is
to Alicia good to see you're on the
board right away congrats there's your
conf
I think the reason and again the
justification you you I don't think they
really told us much it seems like they
word and it was the most
Bland trailer we've seen a hundred times
good points uh all right round two
keeping the Fantastic Four theme going
which I think now we'll have a little
hopefully a little bit more uh fight
here should a fantastic movie be so
serious it feels like uh this was was
this oh sorry this wasn't on Twitter um
it feels like this movie totally we've
all said it they're going that serious
route at the Nolan approach is that how
Fantastic Four I know you guys are now
apparently not fans of the book but you
the comics but you know enough that he's
a stretchy dude she's invisible we know
enough of what the what the G is stry
dude should the movie better title for
the movie actually see stretchy dude
should the movie be taken so seriously
and we're going to start now with you
Alicia I say yes even though the trailer
didn't get me excited I like that the
the tone that they're going for because
of the fact the last fantastic fall
franchise you have to do something
completely different from that and that
just got a little bit silly it was too
much so now to go to in dark tone I
think that's very clever also that's
what fox does really well we've seen
that with Days of Future Past and this
has it the writer from Days of Future
Past to set a superhero world in in a
more realistic setting I think is always
a good move I I always love that when
superhero movies do that and I love the
fact that Josh Tran has said in articles
that he is going for more of a
Cronenberg feel so a science fiction
Cronenberg movie so I I'm still on the
fence about whether it'll be good but I
like the serious tone that they're going
for I think that's the right move Roger
thoughts no it this is a movie called
The Fantastic Four you cannot have a
serious movie about a group called The
Fantastic 4 uh the Hollywood is way too
focused on basically trying to make the
next dark night they they want all these
superhero movies to be dark and brooding
but all the comics we grew up on
including the Fantastic 4 were fun and
that the Fantastic Four of all groups
should be a fun silly movie I know did a
poor job in in the previous Incarnation
but but that doesn't mean with the right
director and the right script it can't
be done but even even more importantly
you have like the old Superman movies
like The Christopher Reed films look how
light-hearted those were but they still
had some seriousness to them but they're
not dark or anything and those movies
were so much fun um and one of the other
things is uh there's the rodri Corman
1994 movie unsee that right we cannot
unsee that but uh it's still it's
actually better than the 2000 ones uh
which is sad because they gave us the
best depiction of Dr Doom and he's
constantly clanking his fingers together
like a classic comic book evil villain
and all uh I think we're missing that
kind of thing and uh one of my favorite
things that's ever been said about the
Fantastic 4 was nor McDonald uh on his
uh comedy album ridiculous he does this
sketch where it's the Fantastic Four
basically arguing about their names the
names who where did Mr Fantastic Reed
Richards get to be called Mr Fantastic
cuz their names are all based on their
powers except for his like and they're
like and I'll be Mr Fantastic yeah
they're like wa what what what guess
with that no you should be stretchy dude
yeah so yeah stretchy dude exactly so I
don't know a group called The Fantastic
4 I cannot take that seriously you just
can't I'm sorry Spencer I think it
should be serious because you can't
unsee what they've done in the past it
is a inherently silly comic book I'm
sorry but the premise of the Fantastic
for is that the ultimate version or
normal is they go on a Weird Science
Mission something happens and then they
all come back with the most random grab
bag of powers that Stanley pulled out of
his acid riddled mind in the 70s right
and you want to make that serious I'm
saying that's your only chance that's
your only hope left is if you make that
just kind of the background and it's
really about you're saying it has bad
characters I think it has bad Powers but
the characters are good you have Reed
Richards who's like this aloof science
genius and he's dating a Invisible Woman
and she literally feels invisible
adopted well and they're these this
Misfit group of teenagers her character
is so poorly written she basically can't
exist without Reed Richards she is not a
good like female icon I'm sorry she's
not she's I'm not saying she's a female
icon I'm saying they're all these flawed
weirdos and that's a story you can tell
whether they have superpowers or whether
they're in you know R um the the person
that everyone loves in the Fantastic 4
is Dr Doom because no one cares about
the Fantastic they just love his costume
they just love looks cool and
intimidating I'm saying if you take
these characters you can try to make a
real serious movie about them and then
they fit in Matthew V's Xmen Universe
you can see them teaming up with fast
Bender thing like Marvel Studios does
the funny thing really well but Fox I
don't think they have that to pull off
yeah they can do the real relatable
character drama and I think it's worth a
shot is there I mean to me there's when
I think what you're saying I think like
Batman and Robin right to the to the end
degree of when they go sort of the silly
lighthearted comic book look way to do
that that's not Batman and Robin like
I'm just curious like well I mean you
know like Tim Burton's Batman I mean
that you know it has like a bit of a
dark tone to it and all but it's still
fun I mean you know look what they did
with the joker and all that stuff and
Catwoman and everything it's great it's
a lot of fun but it's not you know just
like this dark brooding we're all so
cynical and jaded now that we can't have
fun with a comic book movie all I got to
think about is those old Superman movies
those are like the perfect balance I'm
not talking about like Quest for Peace
where it got like totally Bonkers or
that right yeah but I mean Superman 2 uh
super the original Superman those are
fantastic fun movies but they've made
three light-hearted Fantastic Four
movies and they're all terrible yeah
wait they want to do something I'm
counting Corman I count Corman I don't
know about Corman you got to watch that
cor it never came out officially right
it's the entire movie is on YouTube yeah
the Corman one was made just so they
could hold on to the rights they have no
faith in that movie whatsoever it was
the Spider-Man of its de but yes they
they made two bad ones already but that
doesn't mean you know with the right
director in script you can't make a fun
one that's actually good and
entertaining they also had a pretty the
cast was not good uh for that one I I
think the cast on this is where do we
think they went wrong with the new ones
like what what what would you guys say
I'm just curious the the two they St too
close to the comic book they made it to
about four astronauts that go into space
and get hit by gamma rays and then come
back with powers and they focused on
that and them coming to terms with
superpowers instead of who these people
were beforeand I just didn't care about
the characters and I think that's what
it comes down to and I think that's what
this movie is trying to do is to give
you the origin story and make you care
about the characters but I guess what
I'm trying to figure out is did they
take it seriously in those movies think
so not seriously
you they took it seriously enough yeah
they did they they tried the whole the
whole single five seconds he's going
play mom play on they do they Embrace
some of that stuff but they they did a
lot of the serious stuff like especially
the drama between Victor Von Doom and Mr
Fantastic and all that they're previous
background and all they covered all that
and then they try
introducing too ridiculous to make him
the son of a sorcer fromia yeah they
tone that down a little bit ladaria is
in the new trailer and stuff and they're
already to Wikipedia it doesn't mean
anything they're doing it they're doing
it we know they're doing this again this
is just a trailer they're just they're
showing us intercell to deny history you
can't deny history it happens it's on
the record so just for my last sake here
of trying to divy out points what
because I part of me feels like they did
take that now that I'm replaying it back
right the new the old ones did sort of
have some fun with it while they took
this they tried to do what I feel like
you're pitching is what I'm just trying
to see whereas I feel like what uh was
it at least you said putting or who said
putting them in the X-Men Universe both
kind of did we both kind of that that to
me is an interesting point of like we
kind of probably would prefer that in
this day and age for them to be in that
sort of tone did you or did you dislike
the X-Men movies that's I mean I I like
I like the first couple of X-Men movies
I I've we've already talked on the show
that I was not a fan of days of future
best I I thought it was a little too
dark the only thing I liked Quicks was
awesome that was remember we talked
about this like that I wanted to see
just an entire Quicksilver movie but I
thought Days of Future Past was not that
great clever was it was a great movie um
and that was the one fun light-hearted
moment in there and so you can still
have a fun light-hearted moment in
fantastic Fords I'm sure they will but
you can totally see like Miles Teller
and James McAvoy working on some science
thing going off to get Magneto as fast
Bender like they're all the same AG
showing them all all the little kids and
all that stuff yeah like the X-Men I
think it's a really good MCH mix and
match okay so calling it I think uh it's
hard for me to to your arguments were
pretty similar as where I'm struggling
but I think you guys both won so I'm
giving you both
points this mondy seat is
cursed Dan any thoughts uh just a little
cleanup there uh Spencer you said
Stanley pulled their uh powers out of
his Asal mind in the 7 it was actually
the 60s also I don't think he ever took
acid also he probably take and you got
your superhero origins a little mixed up
the Hulk was hit with gamma rays
fantastic for hit with cosmic rays space
mumbo jumbo and also uh stretchy dude
another person who thought that was a
good name for Mr Fantastic was The
Simpsons because in treeh House of horor
10 they all got superpowers and Bart is
the Mr Fantastic like character and he
named himself stretch dude oh nice there
we go good fact there doing your job's
in Honest Trailers about this call it
stretch dude stret SP and Lea got points
on that yes y sorry your arguments you
you pretty much teamed up I'm sorry I
didn't pick one I was gonna but I you
both said interesting things uh round
three we talked a little bit about this
actually in our first episode of movie
fights which you haven't seen go back
and revisit uh we we cast out the
Ghostbusters I think we were pretty
close on a couple of them actually I
called it yeah didn't he he got three
out of four he picked Jones Ernie Hudson
in the Leslie Jones
but some Jones was in it someone did
pick Leslie Jones whether it made it
into like the show or not someone did
actually pick Monday okay uh anyway so
watch that you can you can go back to
the playlist and check it out uh but
we're going to revisit that flight just
because now they finally announced it we
got a lot of comments we're going to do
it again and I don't were you here you
were that episode you were you were way
off so now that we know who it is uh
Christian wig Melissa McCarthy Kate
McKinnon from Sant live and Leslie Jones
from Sant live uh what do we think about
this cast are We excited or is this sort
of an expect choice and we're not we're
still not excited uh we're going to
start with you Roger um I I think it's
semi expected um but uh I'm actually
looking forward to this I think
Ghostbusters 3 was I I it's been in
development hell for a long time we all
know that uh Bill Murray was never
really on board with it Harold Ramis is
now gone uh I I think the whole project
just was going to be awful um so they've
decided to just wipe the Slate clean and
try something different with it
completely I like that uh I think people
are like too hung up on the fact that
it's an all female cast who cares if
they're funny people it's it's got
potential if you have a good writer good
director you can't be a female
Ghostbuster exactly we know they're all
men that's that's Madness um so you know
we have we have that uh I I think it's
premature to write off this movie
because we haven't even seen a trailer
we haven't even seen the logo for it I
mean and I'm sure it's the ghost holding
I I hope so I hope so no it's a reboot
yeah a female ghost yeah female ghost
with a dress doing a
duck little bow on her head like Miss
Pacman or something um so but so you're
you're coming around you're excited now
I I I'm excited for it um I I I think we
have we Leslie Jones and Kate McKinnon
uh they're they're the ones who have
more to prove in this movie uh they
don't have as much uh you know previous
work that we're all familiar with but
Leslie Jones was in a Ghost Chasers
sketch on Saturday Night Live and she
plays this you know just person who's
absolutely terrified of the ghost she
does not want to be there and it was
really funny and Kate McKinnon she's
already proven herself to be pretty
funny uh she did a Justin Bieber
impersonation that is just spoton in
this Calvin kleinet it just it killed it
killed so I I have a lot of faith in
these women I would have liked to see
someone uh like who's not SNL alumni so
a little bit more you know Variety in
there uh but uh you know I'll let I'll
let some of you guys speak Spencer
you're up what do you think I don't want
to see another Ghostbusters but that's
that's the world we live in and here it
is and here's the cast which I'm also
kind of mixed uh mixed levels of
excitement about I really like um Leslie
Jones and uh Kate mckinnel because I
think they're great despite SNL which
has just been in a slump since I was a
teenager I guess everyone says that but
I think that they are The Shining like
examples of what can still be good about
that show so it's exciting to see what
they'll do with hopefully some good
writing and a good director that's
exciting Kristen wig iffy in skeleton
twins but I think she's still has our
trust as a comedic actress to do
whatever and you just got to she great
bridesmaids yeah yeah my problem lies
with Melissa McCarthy and this is just
more of like a personal Vendetta not a
vendetta that's too strong word I just
think that at this point she's Kevin
James in a wig she has just become media
in white face she is so her stick is so
old for me and just she's going to ham
it up in every scene and try to steal it
with like big physical comedy and I'm so
unexcited for that because with the
other three I can see how they could
kind of map on to other original
Ghostbusters with her I just don't see
how she fits in that Dynamic unless
she's Slimer and I'm not I'm excited for
everyone except for mcarthy well it's
interesting too the the plot breakdown
of their characters is she's like the
one who hires them so it seems like once
again with her new spy movie too she's
the wants to be the seems like they
really are going to play the archetype
that she's done again from identity
theft from
he where do you stand this is why my
point is it's completely expected this
cast as soon as we heard that Paul Fe
was going to be directing Ghostbusters
everyone said Melissa McCarthy's going
to be in it and Kristen wigs is going to
be in it and yes the other two are are
new to films but we knew that they would
go for SNL LMS because that's what they
did in the past in the previous
Ghostbusters movie so absolutely
expected and as you guys said Melissa
McCarthy we know she's going to do the
same thing again she does the same thing
every single time I think she's funny
but it's just getting really tiring I'd
prefer that they go for someone
completely different other girls that
are up and coming you know look look to
the Indies get some new faces on there
and just completely different to what we
expected this is exactly what we
expected I love your argument I want to
be clear are you is that how you feel or
are you playing Devil's Advocate CU
we we set up in the first just to be
clear to the viewers I want to be fair
to her so she understands it everyone
was sort of on the same page are you are
you are you standing firm is that your
belief or are you playing Devil's
Advocate on this I I'm kind of half and
half I'm excited but at the same time I
do believe that it's expected so I'm
going to expect it okay you're doing
your it's you're doing this is your own
your your own argument perfect great
this is awesome so what do you it sounds
like you're all pretty much in agreement
really I meanly I mean you know like you
you guys are saying about Melissa
McCarthy she is the one I'm least
excited about and stuff I'm not saying
she can't pull off something good uh but
I would have again I would have liked to
see someone else in there maybe Emma
Stone is someone I thought could
actually do really really well that
would expect let's think about it she
was in Zombie Land she had training from
doct Venkman himself doing some
ghostbusting scene I thought that's
perfect she was great in Birdman so
someone like her I think would have been
a really great character to kind of like
round out the cast someone who's like
yeah because everyone in this movie so
far is a comedian so I think someone
like who's you know a little bit more of
a grounded actress uh versus just pure
comedy would kind of like very good
point but you're going
are you excited or not excited I said no
I'm totally excited about mie now we
have to convince her to be excited and
uh with that in mind I would go for the
two SNL girls uh women are amazing and
how can you not be excited about two
relative unknowns being handed a
franchise that's completely legendary
like that's interesting to see what they
can do I don't think they've ever
they've never starred in a movie I don't
know if they've been in a movie before
but these are two people that really
have done nothing except SNL like that's
interesting that's interesting but it's
also the expected choice that they'd go
for these comedic actresses I'd rather
see course going to do a
comedic
dudy what would have been an interesting
take like how would you have done the
Ghostbusters if if that's what's the
unexpected version to you I I would have
loved people like Lizzy Kaplan I think
she's great that's expected Emma Stone
no it's not Stone would have been
surprising people like that who have who
have been working hard in smaller roles
and to give them a shot at this big
franchise that's what I wanted I think
they're already kind of giving people
big shots in this like these two fairly
you know uh you know new newcomers from
SNL um Ernie Hudson was given a chance
you know I mean that was kind of his his
his big break that's only you know Eddie
Murphy backed out I didn't know that
okay written Freddy Murphy and then he
couldn't do it because of bever Cop 2 I
think or yeah but I mean he he worked
out great and all uh so I I I'm I'm
totally on board with these take a
moment to how cool that would have been
if any mph been in Ghostbusters would
have cro him out that's for like I I'm
glad he chose Beverly's cop cuz that
clearly was an important movie too but I
I remember Ernie actually uh he did an
interview recently about how
disappointed he was because when he took
the role uh he said like his character
was like really fleshed out and
everything and then when he actually got
there and started shooting he doesn't
appear till like the third Act of the
movie I'm just here for a paycheck bye I
think I have a ruling but Dan quickly do
you have you were going to something
real quick just to address uh Spencer's
uh uh state
neither Leslie well Kate McKinnon has
not been in like a major Motion Picture
Leslie Jones was in top
fiveg movie you a whole apple pie so
both of them are pretty much that's
exciting two out of the four
Ghostbusters we've never seen a movie
big Les was her ComEd stand a lot of Stu
she's really funny lots of Television
but no big not a lot of big and this is
a huge franchise real quick though I
have two points that I think are that
are another reasons to be excited about
Ghostbusters 3 first first off it might
bring back highy Ecto Cooler yes if it
brings back highy Ecto Cooler it will
have all been worth it I think we can
agree on that also I'm curious to see if
they have a Janine in this movie and if
it's played by a guy I think that would
maybe be a good flip and they could
bring Paul Rubin in to do it because
Paul Rubin was originally supposed to
play the role of goer in Ghostbusters oh
so I think that would be interesting
like little a little subtle nod to the
original one and we don't see enough
Paul Rubin these days anyway so for
reason Rick moranz would
beely bring him back he needs to come
back in general definitely needs to come
back the world needs Rick Moranis wow
well those two points really just helped
actually helped change my my opinion
that got me excited do you have anything
else cast yeah it's not about nothing to
do with the cast nothing absolutely
nothing yes that is
unconfirmed uh so I got to go with
Spencer is where I'm going just because
I feel like your your your argument of
meliss McCarthy was just too spot on and
anyone you could pull off Media in white
face and actually have me go I kind of
that's sort of I got to give it to
Spencer for having the ball say that out
loud so Spencer gets the point but you
were you were close Sarah but it wasn't
nothing Slaughter
today they better bring back Ecto Cooler
yes they better uh just one quick thing
about Eddie Murphy um and I think we've
made this mistake on screenies too
before he was never actually set to be
in the movie they wrote it with him in
mind but he was never actually like
didn't back out of doing the right do it
CU Beverly Hill's cop was was shooting
so he couldn't do it I'm finding
information that I have is that uh
internet is conflicting report always
conflicting reports but what's cool is
it's going to be on the 40th anniversary
of Stant live did we all hear that he's
finally coming back to appear Ian
rightman says he never came up in the
casting process uh he's just probably in
the face to be nice to Ernie I wanted to
believe Dan ruin your fun press over
there you're ready to believe
but I think that I think that they did
reduce the part of Winston after Eddie
Murphy he confirmed that but it's not
like he was in it and backed out all
right round four we were just talking
reboots right Ghostbusters are rebooting
it's not Ghostbusters 3 which you also
called it uh technically yeah are they
going to call it lady Ghostbusters are
this going to call interesting subject
later we'll figure that out uh but uh
this brings up a question um speaking of
reboots Damen betham on Twitter asked us
what's the best reboot of all time which
is a tough one there's a lot there have
been some good ones uh we're going to
start with uh Spencer this time uh there
have been a lot of reboots you're right
um and my favorite is the Rise of the
Planet of the Apes um which was the
James Franco vehicle and not the Tim
Burton one and I think that we should
judge a reboot on whether it brings
something new to the franchise not
whether it was like a faithful remake of
the original and this was a complete
reimagining and a really interesting one
of some good and legendary but also
fairly campy movies um which were the
original plan of the ape Series so this
is something where they took it and
completely flipped the concept on its
head so you're actually cheering for
Apes to murder all of humanity that's a
tough thing for a movie to do on top of
that they have the only human you
sympathize with is James Franco and
that's the only time that sentence has
been said in the English language they
got you to sympathize with murdering 127
Hours he was pretty he had his moment
yeah um he murdering apes and James
Franco is a tough thing to pull off and
it's just night and day with the
original it's a really fresh take on the
franchise that's my favorite reboot for
the record I think we we can all get on
board with seeing something murder all
of humanity in a movie I mean that's
part of the fun of movies is you can see
that I'm saying hold on what's your
point all right I am going with the Dark
Knight trilogy being the best reboot of
all time because he had Christopher noan
it's got to be Batman Begins yeah Batman
Begins yeah because Christopher Nolan
had such a tough job on his hands Batman
and Robin was the previous film came out
in 1997 made 42 million opening weekend
had production budget of 125 million so
it wasn't a commercial success at all
and it was just ridiculous I'm sure we
can all agree that it just made the
Batman character seem silly Christopher
Nolan took it in a completely different
direction grounding him in reality and
he made me believe that someone would
dress up as a bat and fight crime and
that made sense and at the end of Batman
begins when you see the Joker card and
then they say that oh now the villains
are going to dress up as well that made
complete sense and for someone who's not
a comic book fan for me to totally buy
into that world is something special and
he not only reinvented the character of
Batman but he also reinvented the
superhero genre from then on now we see
a lot of movies striving for that that
dark tone and I think he did such a
great thing for superhero movies and not
only were they critical success but also
a commercial success as well the three
films wow Roger you got a tough one here
that's two really good fights I'll be
honest where you stand talking you're
talking about Reinventing a genre uh I'm
going with the uh 2004 reboot of Dawn of
the Dead um this is a movie that really
kind of changed the face of zombies for
us um we have all these crazy zombie
movies in the 70s and 80s where it's
basically just you know total Gore Fest
with No like real story or anything like
that no human drama or anything it's
just splatter and then the 90s it's it
after Peter Jackson's dead alive it's
kind of like a dead zone of zombie
movies there really was not a lot of
zombie stuff going on but then cut to
the early 2000s and you have uh 28 Days
Later and Dawn of the Dead back to back
and all of a sudden everyone is crazy
about zombies again and it's because of
that uh we get uh stuff like The Walking
Dead because of these movies and it also
introduced so many fun new Concepts uh
my favorite thing in it it introduced
the best game ever which is celebrity
zombie head
shot in the movie they have snipers on
the roof pick sorry uh they're picking
out c zombies that look like celebrities
and they tell their sniper guy all right
find the one that looks like jeno we get
a closeup of a zombie who looks like
jayleno his head just splatters then you
get another one looks like Bert Reynolds
and Rosie O'Donnell it's just it's
hilarious so it's a fun fun movie and it
really re got everyone back into zombies
all right let's fight guys I'm I'm a red
blood American I love zombies and I love
Batman but both of those things were
already really cool before either of
those movies came along we you said 28
Days Later 28 Days Later did come out
like a Dan cam this but it came out a
few years years yeah about two years so
that had already made zombies cool in my
book it was more of an independent film
28 Days Later did come out before 28
Days Later came out in 2002 which is two
years before D so that's already like oh
wow zombies you said but to be clear you
just said there hadn't been so you're
wrong no that's a pretty he said back to
back he said back to back two years
they're pry back to back 28 Days Later
was 28 Days Later came out in the UK it
was an independent film it didn't have a
big budget and it didn't make a ton of
money it made like uh I think it came
like to 40 60 80 mil something like that
total but to people who cared about
zombies it Prov
invigorated was the first one that
really got audiences way back into it
because that one made like over $
hundred million and everything it got
people excited had it had actual big
star power in it which is very unusual
for a zombie movie too you got like Ving
Rams in there and everything oh big star
power I got Ving RS Marcel yeah 28 Days
Later had an $8 million production
budget made 45 million here made 37
million and made $85 million worldwide
really successful how much da the dead
make I'm looking that up right now and
the
production but then now on to the tough
one which is Batman yeah hot one to
argue it's tough to argue against Batman
Begins it's my favorite Batman movie but
Batman had already been Ry rebooted in
the comics with like Dark Knight Returns
and stuff like that so you have that to
draw from plan of the Apes aside from an
amazing twist ending was campy as hell
it was just guys in these bad uh ape
makeup riding around on Horseback
screaming charl and H of let my people
go it was Dumb and the new plan of the
Apes movies are cool and they're
emotional and they're everything that
the originals weren't you can look at
the original Batman's you can look at
the Batman comics and like oh yeah the
Batman comics and it got me really into
the superhero genre Batman Trilogy was
very cool at least people are still
talking about Batman no one really cares
about Planet of the Apes anymore I'm
sorry I'm sorry the last movie the last
movie did not do that great it just was
not very good cool I liked it yeah I can
see
the the I know I feel like it's a lot of
people's favorite
including film of the year made a lot of
money I don't where are these R keep
thr made $78 million
worldwide people did not like that
movie I think that's not
true tell us in the comments below did
you like rise of the plan of the Apes
let's right dawn of the plan of the I'm
sorry Dawn yes the names should be
reversed it should be I'm talking about
the
sequel should have been the first movie
and should have been the second movie of
the Planet of the Apes is 90% certified
fresh on Rotten Tomato so I
think lik it anyway yeah go ahead so but
so so his credit he he makes an
interesting point Batman has been cool I
think both the both rise and Batman
Begins did the same thing for for the
each films like just wiped away the the
previous stench of the last few films
and brought something new but the Batman
Trilogy will be classic forever it'll
live on forever I I don't know if uh
rise and Dawn they're great movies but I
don't know if they'll be Classics that
we'll look back to look da the you can't
say Trilogy though you can only go off
against that's the reboot yeah you have
to go against begins was was pretty good
it was a it was a good start it was a
good start uh set up the time we we were
excited it got
better the second movie is is better
than rise is better than Rise um yes
rise Batman or rise rise of the Batman
ofes all have Dawn and R somewhere in
their name without Dawn of the Dead you
wouldn't one two and I like the counting
without Dawn of the Dead you might not
even have Guardians of the Galaxy cuz
James gun wrote Dawn of the Dead
screenplay he was the one who did that
then he got to do Slither and his career
started taking off we're talking about
the movie we're talking about the movies
uh and you're you've already lost just
cuz your facts are all over the place be
honest all right Dawn of the Dead
introduced in on these two you're
welcome Richard Cheese got introduced to
a wider audience thanks to Don of the
deese I'm CH and it did Inspire my
actual Zombie Survival plan which is to
take a boat to Catalina which um didn't
really work out for them we don't know
but uh it's a great movie I love both of
them uh playing of the Apes just had
such a high hurdle to jump and I think
it did it I think Batman had a a huger
hurdle to jump because of the last few
films were so bad that people lost faith
in Batman as a character on the screen
yeah but people still loved Batman they
were going to see a Batman movie no
matter what they were at least out of
curiosity had there had Iron Man come
out the same year or what had there been
2008 X-Men came out right there had been
serious superhero film since begins or
Batman and Robin before Batman Begins
X-Men came out right Spider-Man came out
those were a little bit but they went in
the same I I this is a tough one I'm
going off the arguments cuz Batman
Begins is one of my favorite films I
actually like Batman be better than the
other two even Dark Knight I think Heath
Ledger is why Dark Knight was so great
but anyway that's my my decide I got to
go with Spencer in this argument because
he makes a really strong point that I
didn't think about which is is they had
nothing to cling from but these really
ridiculous
movies but they get silly and they look
so silly and there's so much against it
and they managed to make a now a two
films in a row that I think against
Roger opinion of not being good but
really strong emotional films that have
re I mean truly rebooted that thing
where I feel like you know the comics
how hard is it to make Batman cool there
were Comics that people he adapted to
Comics like he really did
of the AP better after that Marky Mark
dister no disrespect exactly it's coming
off of that too so no disrespect to noan
he did a fantastic job and did reinvent
superhero and it's classic but for
argument sake I'm going even against my
own and saying Spencer won that so good
work that that was tough for the record
I was playing Devil's Advocate there cuz
I I I do think uh uh Batman but also I
my original choice was the thing John
Carpenter's The Thing we did make you
change the thing I was like no one knows
the
from another yeah I we just thought it
was has anyone seen the re original no
not the original John Carpenters 80s
thing is just an amazing
movie I'm just saying I was playing uh
factchecking that answer and saying I
think that's a very good answer thank
you if you actually search for best
reboots uh best remakes the thing is
like the first thing that ever how you
find
your Google
say very too obscure it was with the
problem too obscure these two I was like
come on that was ridiculous you made a
horror movie and you're calling that
obscure round five fact that it's a
reboot is obscure not it's not a reboot
I don't think it was a close enough it
was technically but it was a remake
anyway uh round five epic Disney news
was announced uh Emma Watson was cast as
Bell OMG guys Hermon is going to now be
Bell herion hermion hery hery that's my
fic yeah uh in the liveaction be of the
Beast this brings up a great question
with Doritos at Dorito
supporter sponsored uh who should play
the Beast hell is going on this this is
an interesting one who should be the
Beast against Emma Watson I imagine
there would be CGI or maybe you'll put
him in a rubber suit this is up for you
to tell me Alicia you're starting Who
Would You cast as Beast well someone
that you don't have to do too much CGI
to turn into a beast is The Rock
Dwayne The Rock Johnson Nick because he
has the stat he feels like a beast he
also looks like he comes her face off oh
it's Nick he also looks like he's H come
straight from a Disney animated movie
the way he's built the way he looks he's
got that proportion he's got the killer
smile Nick has such a boner right now he
not more of a gastan Vibe on Gan but the
thing is I think he could uh he could
also play the prince really well because
he has that charm he is good-looking you
would believe that a girl would fall for
him and you believe that a girl would
fall for him as the Beast as well as the
prince that's why I'm going with the I
do believe a girl would fall in love
with him that's is a very true rer I do
already there there's never been a
prince who could bench press an SUV he's
the Beast he's the Beast he's different
no no uh and then you don't have to do
CGI which you hate lot of protein shakes
in the Middle Ages who are you picking r
uh I'm going with Tom Heston uh this is
a guy who could clearly play a prince no
problem whatsoever uh we're not seeing
enough of Tom hlon that's for sure
everyone loves the guy but he's just not
in enough big movies and all and this is
a role that it really focuses on like a
character with a strong Duality all
right we've we've got this guy who was a
prince we've got this total emotion
because he he gets turned into this
beast and if he doesn't find someone who
loves him he's going to have to remain a
beast the entire time and Tom hson he
can turn that evil switch on and that
scary switch on just on a dime and we
saw him do it like you know in the
Avengers and St he talking to Scarlet
Johansson and all and uh you know he
just suddenly just turns on her and kind
of makes her cry but she was leading him
on and all that but anyway uh the point
is is he can actually play these two
characters extremely well and uh I'd
like to see him uh take it on Spencer
okay well talk about no CGI my answer is
Mickey Rook the wrestler um no CGI as
the beast but but he can't be a prince I
think that it's more that's what you
need the CGI for it's more important to
stick the role of the Beast to make this
movie believable cuz this works uh for
the majority of the time on this
repulsive man with this sweet soft
inside and that is Mickey roor he's had
in real life like one of the biggest
rise Falls rises again uh of anyone's
career he's gone broke he's had drug
problems he's come back his own face is
messed up which sounds perfect for a
Disney movie doesn't it I think that for
the role of the Beast that this really
works and you want to believe that uh
this sweet guy would be repulsive that
Emma would not want to you know make I
don't want to say them together that's
weird Emma want Mick what I don't want
to see though bet he'd be into it into
it yeah he really would he really would
a couple responses to that
one I don't want to see that together
either so so you get a different guy
when he transforms he transforms into
the
transforms what you guys what you guys
are proposing is two beautiful people
with like a scar on their face like oh
oh I'm not going to make out Tom Heston
he's got like a weird hairy eyebrow like
or he's got a weird um the rock as like
a a cleft pallet like no these people
are going to be good-looking no matter
what Tom H Tom hson or the rock if you
put them in Beast makeup they're not
going to be pretty if that's up to the
the costuming department they're not
going to be they're not going to be
scary yes they nck Ro is scary as F you
it's a story about what's really on the
inside of a person and Mickey Ro fits
that perfectly look I don't want to see
I think he's scary on the inside too
both of these both of these men are
giant tiny dogs both of these men are
giant beasts who I do not want to see
with Emma Tom you could totally see
doing it they're closer age range for
one Tom Tom is uh 32 33 he's older than
that no I think no I've res I think we
all agree we we'd much prefer him kiss
Emma Watson Micky thank you how old is
Emma Watson 2 she's like 25 I think this
is Hollywood it doesn't matter I'm glad
it's not creepy to ask that question
anymore you guys are 2 you guys are all
hung up on the kiss which is one creepy
moment but the story is about a really
ugly disfigured person that is falling
in love or being put in the friend zone
it's about a prince who's turned into a
ugly disfigured person and all that and
it's not about play by either Hemsworth
is the prince he turns into Mickey and
then he turns back into hensworth at the
end who doesn't want to see that he's a
better actor than either of those
I I can just call it now I feel like
it's pretty clear and I think you're
crazy
Spencer I want a good movie not a disne
movie I think you're crazy cuz Roger hit
everything I think fairly the best one
the rock you don't want the prince to
Ben bench press he said a very valid
point you you don't need CGI for you
shouldn't have CGI for the prince like
Tom hson is an actor like he can act
like right like I they're going to put
like a weird mark on his ey
a great actor we don't see enough on the
board with a point
Y I would contend Roger though you said
there's never been a prince that could
bench press in SUV I would say Prince
Adam from
He-Man no no Prince Adam it's only
He-Man who can do the bench he looks the
same he's got the same that's muscles
this is a debate for another time but I
I totally the one thing about man that
is always driven me nuts is we never see
him turn back into Adam it's just like
he's like all right well I guess my
powers are worn off or something but you
look at any Disney Weir his muscles
don't go away I don't know how to use
these muscles where did I leave my tunic
all right round
six so Roger still has a shot here now
remember the winner uh the first I mean
the two winner uh two winners with the
most points goes the speed round in
round eight uh so be prepared it's
anybody's game still this is my round
round six and right now the scor for
everyone at home we have three for
Spencer correct me if I'm wrong two for
Alicia and one for Roger all right I'm
correct okay at some point we'll get a
scoreboard going uh round six um since a
lot of you are gearing up to watch the
Super Bowl today or you you've saved us
until after the Super Bowl either way
magic um it's the best day to go to
theme parks today uh the Grant T tabard
on Twitter asked us what's the best
sports movie of all time we don't
usually handle Sports on here but I
think Super Bowl Sunday it's fitting
what's the best sports movie and we're
going to start with you Roger the best
sports movie of all time is Rocky 4
there is no question about this because
this is a sports movie that actually
gets people who are not sports fans to
watch it you see that trailer you want
to watch this movie it doesn't matter
whether you're into boxing or not you
want to see this happen can you just
remind I know it but for those at home
walk me through Rocky believe me believe
me we open on the Russian Tong right so
uh Rocky's best friend Apollo Creed
spoiler alert yes Rocky's best friend
Apollo Creed uh wants to get back into
boxing uh uh this giant Russian Mammoth
Champion comes to America saying he
wants to start fing so Apollo Creed sees
this as like his golden opportunity they
have this exhibition match together
which is preceded by a performance by
James Brown no less which is incredible
in its own right seeing Carl Weathers
dancing with him in full American Uncle
Sam gear he gets in the ring starts
doing okay at first and we're like all
right no no big deal then suddenly I
Drago the Russian just unloads on him
just the hardest punches we've seen in a
boxing
movie he takes down he kills Apollo
Creed with one punch very unexpected yes
yes and it's just like the franch so
Rocky seven montages later Rocky wins
okay Rocky sees this happen revenge and
he goes to Russia to fight not for money
but for revenge and the I'm going to end
the Cold War yes I'm going to cover much
more of this got else Spencer Rudy Rudy
Rudy rocky rocky rocky yeah Rudy is the
best moment of any sports movie of all
time is the climax of Rudy but I just
love this that it's really it's it's
like about this five foot nothing kid
who the the bad guy isn't Ivan Drago
it's not some cartoon character pulled
out of Sylvester Stallone's uh also a
drug addled mind but it's about him
against himself it's about this kid that
has no business playing football much
less at Notre Dame and it's really more
in tune with what sports are about which
is just never giving up and perseverance
and uh overachieving Beyond uh beyond
what you're capable of I've heard that
story before oh it was called Rocky this
was okay was Rocky a real guy no cuz
Rudy ruer was Rocky well Rocky was he
was you're right I'm sorry about that
Rocky he was but they're both like
actually Rudy isn't really uh they take
some Liberties too but I think that this
is so cool how the bad guy in this movie
is Rudy himself it's just a kid who has
no reason being there but oh my God when
he gets to that Climax and John Fabro is
like you're the wild man now and they
lift him on their shoulders and carry
him off there is not a more manly tears
have been shed in that moment than in
World War II or at any point in time
like it is the best climactic movie
moment of all time and it happens to be
in a sports
movie well I'm going to say Field of
Dreams is the best sports movie of all
time because the the best sports movies
are not actually about sport themselves
they're about much more and things that
you can relate to if you're not a sports
lover like me I don't care about
baseball I don't know anything about it
at all but I Love Field of Dreams
because it is about idealism it's about
the uh you know your father son
relationship which you can relate to
even if you are a girl the playing catch
with your dad at the end that kills me
every single time it's about yeah
hearkening back to to a a better time
and the idea of baseball for me growing
up in Australia was always that it's the
American dream and that seems like such
a lovely thing to do a lovely Pastime
and lovely experience that you can share
with your family and I never cry in
movies but Field of Dreams gets me every
single time so that's why I think it's
the best sports movie ever it makes a
non sports lover really get into it if
you build it stop it stop it what do you
guys think all right fight that gives me
chills that gives me chills look I'm I'm
just going to paint a picture for you
here all right this is a beautiful
picture ridiculous it's so over the top
but I love it exactly you want to talk
about something that brings tears we
know how great it is I don't want you to
read your list I want you to why does
Rocky beat these two that's the battle
I'm I'm going through this look I I I
went I worked hard on this never brought
in notes
before all the movies I'm not giving you
a I'm not giving you a list list come on
look I'm I'm I worked hard on this
Captain
America Ser just for
all right so we have the best training
montage in the history of film it's all
right I want you to fight these movies I
don't want you to tell I know why the
movie is great we all have agreed it's
great why is it better than these two
movies read list it has this training
montage it we have rocky like eight
training like many you're basically
saying you're basically saying don't
talk about your movie against these
movies compare it to these comp I'm
telling you why it's better because it
inspires have a montage does it feel the
dreams have aage
build it inspires people the sound have
a
montage even Rocky had a montage this
inspired all future montages look Rocky
had a montage okay I'm talking I'm
talking against the movies here against
these other movies Rocky's Music alone
inspires people you've worked out to
Rocky's Music That's Rocky all the go to
your mic go to your mic Rocky for music
uh look you you have Burning Heart and
Eye Of The Tiger by Survivor Hearts on
Fire by John Cy Living in America by
James I'm doing it I don't care I worked
hard on this look and look if the
trailer can even get you so excited you
see two gloves explode but the most
important thing about Rocky the most
important thing about Rocky is it ended
the Cold War Rocky for ended the Cold
War gorbachov actually attended the
fight in in the movie and we see was not
really him not really it's a fake I'm
saying was not in Hot Shot great movie
uh uh but no he ends the Cold War and he
turns a hostile crowd uh completely for
him and he he basically makes everyone
root for America and him and it makes
you feel like you can do anything Rocky
climb I got to get through the other
people's thoughts and Dan quickly Roger
I the tiger is not from Rocky 4 it's
from rocky3 no it's in it's on the
soundtrack it's on the it's on the
soundtrack heing his list which Thank
You For Preparing but why is are your
films better than the other two yeah to
compare our two uh we both like them for
the same reasons as that they're about
something more than the sport they're
about the heart they're about the
relationships and the universal struggle
that anyone can relate to why I don't
like Field of Dreams is it's about
baseball and baseball is the most boring
sport I actually do like sports except
for baseball which is more of a human
aquarium where you just watch stats go
up and down I just can't get by it's a
inherently not cinematic uh sport dis
agree I you're like seeing this through
the the rosecolor glasses of someone
that didn't grow up in America and have
to sit through three to four hours of
baseball games to baseball game since
I've been here and I love it because
it's so American it's such a great
American Pastime and it stood for the
60s idealism in an 80s world I love that
football and Rudy by extension manages
to mix the heart and and the drive and
the
intensity people in the world there's
some actual believable football scenes
in that movie more or less was an
Australian football movie maybe it's a
better sports movie than Field of Dreams
which is really just a a drama well
that's it that but it's no it's about
more than just Sport and that's why I
love it so is Rudy so is Rocky Rocky is
more is definitely more than boxing
exactly it is it is far beyond it and
look guys if I can change you can change
and you can change everybody can change
well so I have a struggle of you you
both yours is I'm not disputing your
your film it's a great film Rocky is as
well like I mean there's several of them
but the only point is you both have
these really emotional strong they're
not just all about the sports what you
relate to and I relate to the the family
aspect and mine is based on a real
character and yours is a weird ghost
fantasy but to make that work isn't that
brilliant believe that is impressive
that they made it work that it really
gets to you even though it is ridiculous
on paper but it's not really a sports
movie I guess that gets into that
argument that we don't want to have but
of a sports movie come on Dan it's Field
of Dreams a sports movie yeah
Al you got me your last Point that's
what I needed I needed one more little
piece of argument all also Roger you're
right you're right about I the tiger
there also Rocky for so thank you cor
retra cam just Dan correction retracting
well I wouldn't expect much from the
coward
cam not defending his title two weeks in
a row
here bu we're building that's not he
would be here if heow he did not that
was producers calls we decided to have
him sit so we can build up who if you
win today you can take I can't now you
got to win Roger I can't round seven
yeah can if I may say unless Roger takes
Devil's Advocate and wins on this round
he's mathematically eliminated from
going to the uh to the speed round high
stakes very good point would you like to
take devil after might as well why not
this is important one this is a big one
this is probably our title out you might
have been waiting this whole move show
just for this one uh we decide that
after our show so we don't know yet
what's on our thumbnail uh but this
question is tied into our honest trailer
for this week which happens to Star
Chris Pratt that's your teas you could
say it's awesome oh well thanks Spencer
I guess he only been in like two movies
so it's not that hard to figure out
anyway Chris Pratt now the the man in
charge of Hollywood at seemingly uh
Disney wants him to be the next Indiana
Jones I want each of your thoughts on
this casting of Chris Pratt uh well
actually no we're we're I'm sorry we're
readjusting this question which I think
is coming on screen so Alex Dr question
asked us on Twitter asked do we want an
Indiana Jones reboot we all everyone
doesn't want to reboot as well yes I do
let things I do now oh I so exced I
cannot wait for fine we were going to
say do we want with Chris Pratt I think
that we'll let both things in do we want
an Indiana Jones reboot and do we like
Chris Pratt so we're starting with you
Spencer so yeah the the question I
prepared for was more Chris Pratt based
but I'll go I I don't care
I can argue for why we should not want
an Indiana Jones reboot and that's
basically we need to let things die we
don't need to dig up the corpse of
Indiana Jones just because Chris brat is
a popular actor and Disney has the
rights there's no reason for another
Indiana Jones movie to exist beyond the
fact that he's a hot uh commodity right
now and that they could hot property
that we' have already driven this
franchise into the ground to such a
shameful place that we should only we
should just let it die and that's really
the Alicia do we want to reboot no we do
not want to reboot because I don't want
to ruin the three movies any further IND
movies I'm refusing to acknowledge the
fourth movie because it was so bad but
the three was such a part of my
childhood and it's always special and I
rewatched them not very long ago and I
still love these movies so it doesn't
need to be rebooted there's nothing that
needs to be fixed about the movies if
you want to use the for marketing then
do a spin-off or do something completely
different with it but don't do a reboot
however so like James Bond you're saying
yeah like James Bond is technically
those
reboots different stories of episodes
theyve always switched bonds I mean
they've been doing that forever so I
think that the Daniel Craig ones kind of
they they kind of marketed themselves as
a reboot because they rebooted the
character but generally no it's just
somebody else Tak do a spinoff but if
you have to do Indiana Jones and this is
the world that we live in that Hollywood
is just going to keep remaking things
because it's easy to Market to places
like China and Russia who already know
the name then you should go with someone
like Chris Pratt because he has the
charm he's pretty much Harrison Ford
already Guardians of the Galaxy he
played Han Solo and when I spoke to him
for Guardians of the Galaxy I said who's
your favorite character Hans Soler or
Indiana Jones straight away he said
Indiana Jones and because he has that
passion for it then if we have to do it
I think he's the right man for the job
he's got the charm and the good looks
and I'd like to see him in a Fedor goad
guys I am so excited for Indiana to be
rebooted I I cannot wait for them to
reboot this so be decar Roger is Playing
devil's advocate because he does not
believe this and if he wins he gets
double points we were talking about
movies that make us cry just thinking
about a reboot it's it's bringing tears
to my eyes right now the whip back the
whip in the Hat so so look uh we you
know it's it's it's a lot of fun to say
you know Indiana Jones ended with the
Last Crusade but it it didn't it didn't
they made they made the Crystal Skull
and that left a real bad taste in our
mouth and they made it many years later
so the current younger generation that's
that's a lot of their impressions of
Indiana Jones a lot of them have not
seen the earlier ones so they think
they're just these crappy movies why I
mean if you see Crystal Skull you're not
going to care to go watch the other ones
if that's like your introduction Indiana
Jones so that scares me hey let me no
I'm talking about this awesome movie
that's it's got a point some people Bas
Star Wars on the Phantom men right so
you know I want I I think there's
nothing wrong they have nowhere to go
but up from Crystal Skull and you know
Chris Pratt you know he is the best of
the people out there right now for the
Indiana Jones role I mean he he has the
looks for it he's got the Charisma he's
got the fan base and everything just
like Harrison Ford did when he was going
Indiana Jones so you put him in this
movie you do a good job you totally
reboot it and just kind of set these new
Origins for Indie have him go on a brand
new adventure and you can get kids and
everyone interested in Indiana Jones
again then they will go back and watch
the original trilogy which is absolutely
Timeless it's great w guys Roger
stepping it up I'm impressed that's
great on your all right so guys fighting
Roger why is he wrong yeah I just think
we're about to get I'm not sick of Chris
Pratt right now I love him to death he's
amazing we're about to get really sick
of Chris Pratt he's about to be in every
single movie that comes out in the next
two or three years you can see what he's
got coming up but I know there's
Guardians to there's going to be
Jurassic world there's going to be uh
somebody what was it called I wrote down
is a cowboy ninja Viking he's going to
be in sounds Lego Movie Lego Movie too
and he's going to be Indiana Jones all
right Lego Movie let someone else have a
role voices are are fine that's that's
not going to like make you feel
oversaturated with them we have not
after after Indiana Jones comes out
maybe we'll be at the point of over
pretation but right now we're not at
that point Alicia you like Chris prep
but you don't want to reboot I don't
want to re why don't you want to
rebuilding why is Roger wrong the three
films are great they should re-release
the three films and put them on their
timelist they were made to feel like a
throwback to 30s Cals and they have that
great nostalgic feel already they don't
need to do it again and and what would
you want from the reboot would you want
the same three forget the fourth same
three movies going be fighting Nazis in
the 19 no I just I just said we want we
want a reboot something completely
different he doesn't have to
be look how about this maybe maybe he's
searching for the lost city of Atlantis
that would be a cool thing this it's
this big mystical you don't have
to why not no search for weird forgot we
can go on total Adventures you don't
have to have Nazis involved or anything
like that na exactly you don't I say I
got to say Roger you pulled it out there
I I mean there was a whole TV show The
Young Indiana Chronicles which proved
you can do fun installments of the show
there are books there are games there
it's a it's an iconic character I just
don't want to be explaining to my
children when they say Indiana Jones oh
do you mean Chris Pratt or Indi or
compon for it going to have to have that
convers I don't want to explain to my
children oh do you mean Crystal Skull no
why can't they do a new episode like
they do with Star Wars Star Wars episode
7 rather than doing redoing the the well
you would it would be shy La Bo is that
what you guys W no he he adopted a new
kid that was if they were to go on that
trap you know that's where it would go
and then just have him
in I think is he's too Goofy for Indiana
Jones it should be Bradley Cooper but
that was the argument prep for and we're
having this one it's a given that we
shouldn't redo Indiana Jones I can't
believe we have to argue that Bradley
Cooper does not have have that same
Charisma as Chris Pratt he does not have
he does not have the face for Indiana
Jones and a lot of people are not on
board with Bradley now after uh the
sniper movie so he got nomination I
think a lot of his performance you were
up against the wall Roger and you pulled
it off you did it I'm giving you the two
point don't agree but I didn't think you
do it you pull the Devil's Advocate that
gives him two points the first time ever
one of Devil's Advocate you get two
points wow so that just made you and
Alicia tied Spencer are right that means
on oh sorry it's a three-way tie okay so
uh how do we figure this
out crap well I have a couple tie bre
here let's do all right speed rounds uh
he does this are they either or or like
what are we going do I think
uh uh we're going to pick the two I have
two tie Breakers here all right you
whoever gets it first moves on the last
round and then the next two whoever gets
that moves on that with them yes that's
how we're going to do it the rules are
changed as we go that's how movie fights
work this three person speed this is a
threepers speedrun which we've never
done here on movie fights yeah uh we are
going to ask you a question you're going
to have to answer quickly if you all say
the same thing it's whoever answered
first right if you don't and you said
something else you can you can quickly
do it but we have to do it quickly
because I don't want to sit here for 3
minutes doing a speed round we have to
do do fast everyone understand the rules
yes speed
round Michael Hill on uh at the doctor
2012 asks best movie voice Morgan
Freeman or James R Jones Jones I heard
James R Jones James Jones and then
Morgan Freeman you're out Spencer uh why
James Jones and then you're answering
why Morgan Freeman uh Darth Vader I mean
how how how much more iconic can you get
than than Darth Vader's voice uh it's
just it's incredible it's something that
people talk about you never see his face
the entire movie it is all James Earl
Jones because of that Alicia Morgan
Freeman Morgan Freeman has one of the
most iconic voices ever in movie history
he's you can do God he's red he makes
you believe in hope I want him to do my
voicemail cuz he has such a great voice
he has such a commanding presence you
hear it and you feel you feel comforted
and he's narrated many films because he
has such a great all those things too
but I got to say Darth Vader cuz Darth
Vader wins but that was close Rogers in
the finals ah wow from behind so he gets
an extra point so did these points count
toward his final total gets a point and
now we have one more speed round to get
see who is going to challenge Roger it's
just between you two Roger you're you're
safe are we ready Michael Wheeler o that
Michael Mr I'm sorry Michael Wheeler o
that Mr Wheeler on Twitter asks best
Michael man directed film that isn't he
collateral you have to wait till the
answer I think he can still say it right
he can say he just jumped I mean at
least his answer counts you still answer
what you had
quickly sorry what did you sayal you
said collateral I would have said
collateral that was my second answer
yeah you got it Alicia's
in went from the top to the
bottom speeduns my
heel it was so close yeah so now are we
going through like a full speed round of
like five questions whatever five quick
speed round questions this five uh yes
yeah best of five we have five tied best
of five you guys are tied uh what is the
Tie so we understand three it's five
right or one well they both what so it's
four to four to four we're going in on
this you'll help me keep scoring this
sir Here We Go Round uh speed round we
all understand how this works you just
did one same same same
way once again we've asked this before
but a movie is playing on cable which
one should we watch Beverly Hills Cop 2
or Ghostbusters
to the
point ready number two let's trying to
look but Hollywood's best Tom Tom
Hanks
uh
Tom
Bergeron uh Tom Hardy why oh Tom Hanks
is is such an incredible actor he uh
makes you believe that life is more than
just a box of chocolates he can he can
carry Cast Away just by himself with a
volleyball he makes you feel something
he's so famous but you still believe him
in every single role Roger uh Tom Hardy
has not seen his uh best days behind him
like Tom Hanks has Tom Hardy is Captain
pH Tom Hardy is still moving forward he
he was he I mean a lot of people didn't
care for dark KN RIS but Bane everyone
loves Bane he's a fun character uh he he
just did the movie The the driving one
I'm totally blanking on on the name
right now well that's not helping you
TKS all right we're tied again yes mhm
number three right tough number three
which movie star would you would be more
fun to share an Uber
with Meg Ryan or Reese Witherspoon Reese
with spoon Meg Ryan why okay okay Reese
with spoon has a dark side to her she
may come across as very like lovely but
she's actually got some fun to her we
see that in Wild plus she's quite sweet
I don't know I'm just keep going like
this uh Meg Ryan is actually sweet she
was America's sweetheart whereas ree
Witherspoon was actually pulled over by
police and she's just like unleashing
like she gets pulled off by the cops she
gets pulled off by the cops and you're
left there she's you're just stranded
and you're talking about getting a ride
that's why she's fun yeah spoon she's
more fun I don't get a ride she wasn't
pulled over her husband was she still
went crazy she did would defitely
Point all right one at least she winning
by one wait wait so who gets that who
wins that at least she get the point at
Le she gets the
point what's the best Christmas movie
that's okay to watch during the rest of
the year Christmas
Vacation answer was Die
Hard the answer is always elf and
Christmas Vacation why elf elf is so
much fun every time I watch it it makes
me laugh and it has nothing to do with
the fact that it's around Christmas it's
just will Ferell has gives such a good
performance I think it's one of the best
comedies ever not just Christmas movies
uh Christmas vacation is the iconic
Christmas movie and it doesn't really
matter that it is just Christmas you you
have Chevy Chase you have the whole
Griswald Clan uh you have their
neighbors uh Chevy Chase coming out
looking like a chainsaw wielding Maniac
I mean this is a movie that has all the
best things about the vacation films all
wrapped into one thing and I can watch
at any time and it does air during the
regular Year all the time oh that's
tough actually I need some help on one
guys well it would decide the winner if
I went one way or the other and I I
think I should recuse myself I could my
opponent for the title B so I'm going on
you man I'm not Tak any thoughts elf is
a
quotable they are both quotable my
favorite I know it should be die hard
but yeah it was supposed to die answer
it was going to say who said Die Hard
first was going to win I know that's why
I didn't go die this is the fourth
question argument this is the fourth
fourth question yes okay uh and if
Felicia wins it she wins the game and
I'm going to go off of what you said you
said it plays more but I feel like I see
them both play more say all the time and
I feel like Christmas is in the title of
your movie and she made a point elf was
not really about Chas yes it is it's
about my guys it was a tough one how I
forget that wow Alicia pulls through at
the very end there that was a very
intense battle you everybody ala will be
back make sure we fre your schedule we
will tell you're going to come back to
take that champion on against comic book
around 19 I think is that the first no
one of the first wins on a first round I
think she we have two in a row
now I really badly so two main
competitors here I got to start training
now because I have two worthy very good
I want to scare you # coward cam okay uh
I want to thank I promise some teasing
so next week's movie fights to help we
have your most requested guest ever I
think is that fair by far we'll be doing
a special episode of movie fights just
Nick Monday Jeremy John's is coming next
week to movie fights we're very excited
to have him uh we don't know who he's
battling yet who do you want to see him
battle not Dan I think we're going to
keep Dan out well maybe not tell us who
you want to see him battle on Twitter
hasht Twitter screenies at Andy signor
tell us who you want to see also in the
comments on YouTube who would you see
and want to see him battle because he
lives in Seattle watch I think he's in
he can't do this regularly so the title
bout's not in it it's just going to be a
fun battle with the most requested
guests we have the week after will be
the title bout with Dan Merl takes on
you Alicia and comic book girl 19 to see
who is the now going to keep that belt
so very exciting stuff to come and when
you tear that belt from his cold dead
hands uh I want you to come back on the
show every week and defend it like a
true champion well no we won't let her
do that cuz we want it to be we want to
build up we want the people so uh thank
you everybody uh make sure you please
check us out on iTunes rate comment
subscribe uh also on YouTube if you're
listening on iTunes uh youtube.com/
screen yunies uh popcorn Talk network so
many great shows there meet the movie
press Marvel movie news Jedi Alliance
Theos no's profiles Schoo podcast go
check them out please links are in the
description please please please go
support them also I want to make sure
you guys know on break.com mov you can
watch fulllength stream movies there are
ones that are screen junkies approved
please go check out a movie and go tell
them that screen junkies sent you we
want to go support that uh it's very fun
thing that we are involved in to help
get some fun free movies out for you
guys to see is Halloween on there I want
if I maybe go check it out I don't know
I think a lot of the leper movies are
stuff um uh I want to thank our
panelists here Spencer Gilbert at
Spencer jgilbert thanks so much thanks
man I'm clearly better in writing then I
am in
person very close Alicia Malone wow you
killed it at Alicia Malone correct
anything you'd like to plug I'm sweating
I'm sweating just uh watch profiles on
popcorn Talk network we're doing Tom
Hanks next week on your brain Roger bar
at IM mockery I'm so sorry you were
close you pulled it ahead anything You'
like to plug uh yeah follow me on
Twitter IM m o c k r y go to imo.com my
YouTube channel is youtube.com/ rogar
and also #g Roger Ecto Cooler I'm on
board with that on the danam back in and
in charge it's Dan Merl at at Merl Dan
at Merl Dan I look forward to seeing
Roger and Nick in the audience for the
first title bout and uh to come watch
can we
do I'd like to say happy birthday to my
mom a very nice thank that's happy yes
happy birthday Mrs Merl and please
follow me on uh Twitter or Instagram at
Andy signor I am going to tease
something that I probably was not
supposed to but I'm just going to
because I'm sort of the boss we have an
epic collab coming on this week's honest
trailer call it epic it's epic follow me
on Instagram and Twitter and Andy signor
and I'll give you the tease cuz I'm
mature who's the p ping seriously this
one's good come check it out and
obviously please tell us what you want
to see on the show who you want us to
get to come fight all those fun things
uh and please also hashtag speedr I want
some more speedr questions in Twitter so
all you fans out there send us a bunch
you guys aren't allowed to check them uh
but just send them so we have some
options thanks so much for everybody see
you next week I hope the Super Bowl was
fun and hopefully our show was better
have a great one see watch us inside of
the Super Bowl
yeah every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this kickass graphic listing
all the topics your favorite screen
junkies podcasters are talking about if
you click the topics you can skip around
and choose your own podcast Battle
Royale go ahead try them all if you
haven't already subscribe to screen
junkies on YouTube to join us for future
fights or if you prefer to listen on
iTunes click the logo to download an
audio version lastly please support our
friends at the popcorn Talk network for
more awesome
shows